[Music]
moon knights may not have seemed to be
tied into the wider marvel cinematic
universe but what was with that falcon
in the winter soldier shout out and was
that a hippo keep watching for the
easter eggs in moon night that totally
slipped by you
in the second episode of moon night
after being fired stephen grant decides
to investigate the clues found in his
apartment that leads him to a very
raiders of the lost ark style building
filled with storage units the contents
of number 43 reveal a whole lot about
mark spector but one thing that may go
unnoticed is the date on his passport
the passport was issued in december of
2018 which doesn't mean much by itself
until one takes into account that the
snap in avengers infinity war occurred
earlier that year from that we can
conclude that moon knight has been
active for the last five years or so
either in his superhero persona or just
as mark spector meaning that he was part
of the population that didn't disappear
during the snap he also shares a
birthday with the man portraying him
oscar isaac which is a neat little
connection though spectre is 8 years
younger than isaac
as it stands moon knight is keeping its
connection to the mcu subtle but there
was a notable reference to the falcon
and the winter soldier in episode 2.
steven grant tries his hand at fighting
a jackal-like creature in the streets
but eventually gives in and allows the
more experienced mark spectre to take
over in an exciting transformation
sequence the shot just after this shows
a full view of the london bus featuring
an ad for the global repatriation
council also known as the grc this is an
organization that was plot crucial to
the falcon and the winter soldier after
half of the earth's living creature
suddenly returned most of the humans
would need help getting re-situated
reuniting with family finding work or
just coming to grips with what happened
that's what the grc provides it makes
sense that there would still be some
promotions for the group at this time
but as an extra nod to moon knight the
full ad reads reuniting you with your
better half though it might be an odd
word choice for single people who came
back in the blip it works perfectly for
the character of moon knight at this
moment oh and one more quick easter egg
here it flashes by quick and is upside
down for the viewer but the top of the
bus also has wbn 0032 printed on top of
it a reference to werewolf by night
number 32 moon knight's comics debut
as layla and steven get to know each
other a bit better in his flat she
snoops around his belongings in an
attempt to figure out what happened to
mark spector her husband looking across
his book collection she spies a familiar
name a collection of poems from
marceline de belt valmar a moment later
stephen begins reciting one of the poems
called le c'est pare translating to
apart aloud in french and layla joins in
saying the lines with him she's my
favorite poet
um no she's my favorite
the implication of how this knowledge
subconsciously worked its way into the
creation of the steven grant identity is
quite interesting on a different but
equally deep note the poem itself
discusses two separated lovers and
repeats do not write which in this case
could reference the fact that mark cut
off communication with her other than
mailing divorce papers to further this a
bit and help connect it back to moon
knight the poem goes on to say to knock
at my heart is like knocking at a tomb
which ties into any number of scenes in
the series there are also a couple quick
easter eggs in the following sequence
once steven is captured by harrow's
bogus agents his file number begins with
1975 the year moon knight debuted in the
comics and the agent assigned him is
listed as nick pepin a production
manager on moon night
steven grant seems like a lonely guy so
it's no surprise that he would befriend
someone who's a captive audience and
appears to be a good listener when most
viewers saw him talking to the golden
living statue they assumed it was
potentially a reference or sly nod to
something from the comics and some even
guessed correctly who it was but one of
the show's writers has now officially
confirmed that the silent busker is in
fact another of moon knight's allies
bertrand crawley posing as a living
statue makes sense as crawley likes to
embrace his dramatic side at times and
being out in public like that also helps
in his role as a street level informant
this version of the character doesn't
have flies swarming around him or many
teabags handy but when he does finally
speak it will most likely be in the
character's posh british accent the
former textbook salesman might not be
speaking to stephen currently because in
the comics he is the contact of another
personality jake lockley meaning that
this other version of the familiar face
could be throwing him off crawley's
inclusion could also lead to a future
villain his son known as slasher or it
could just be a clever cameo either way
many fans are hoping to see more of the
characters soon
during the sham of a trial against
arthur harrow in episode three konshu
speaks to the other egyptian gods and
begs them to pay more attention to this
realm and leave the overvoid it's a word
that is easy to miss during an
impassioned scene but this reference
also hints at where most of these other
gods reside that is if they aren't
spending their time as a stone statue or
palling around earth with their avatars
in an incorporeal form with a
disembodied voice these gods unlike some
of the creatures that are called gods in
the mcu but are more like aliens such as
the asgardians and eternals cannot
physically walk upon the realm of men
with their full power this is why they
need avatars like mark spector and
steven grant in the first place as such
the overvoid sometimes called the
celestial heliopolis is where the gods
exist on a different plane or pocket
dimension in the comics the overvoid is
sometimes depicted as a floating white
pyramid and is mentioned that the gods
used to be able to move freely across
the realms but have been trapped there
now for quite some time in this the
overvoid acts as a majestic home but
also a prison giving the gods an excuse
not to interfere in earth's affairs
without the magic scarab to guide him
mark spector and layla have to discern
where amit's tomb could be another way
this eventually leads him to anton
mogart and his collection of stolen
antiquities he classifies it as
preservation but it isn't hard to see
that he's beyond wealthy and gets what
he wants when we first see mogart he is
showing off on horseback and seems to
have a way with leyla but plays the
charismatic and welcoming host things go
awry shortly after and moon knight ends
up fighting mogart and his armed guards
this is all a familiar rivalry from
comics mogart is known as midnight man
in the comics a thief who strikes
precisely at the stroke of midnight
during one of his scrapes with moon
knight mogart was washed into the sewers
and disfigured driving the villain mad
and putting him on a path of revenge
including midnight man in the show
seemed to be setting up story lines for
future seasons but tragically the actor
who played mogart gaspar julio passed
away in january 2022 whether marvel will
choose to recast the role or not remains
to be seen
as layla points out to mark in episode 3
they're in her home now cairo egypt
seeing these two working together is
entertaining but it is heavily hinted at
that this isn't layla's first rodeo
during an exchange with anton mogart's
bodyguard we learned that she and mogart
got tangled up on a previous mission and
the location of that mission will sound
very familiar to fans of the mcu after
madrid i'm sure you two will have a lot
to talk about
the principality of majapur is a haven
for pirates criminals and entrepreneurs
without morals it's a dangerous place
with a clear class divide and almost no
laws which is perfect for someone trying
to hunt down stolen relics or just as a
location to make the trade this island
was shown off in the falcon in the
winter soldier alongside sharon carter's
power broker character who was rumored
to have a cameo in moon night though
that ultimately didn't happen
moon knight evidently enjoys its deep
cuts from the comics and assigning
people obscure names that only appear in
a single issue this seems to be the case
with karish beck who is simply referred
to as beck in the show and acts as a
bodyguard of anton mogart when leyla and
mark meet mogart in egypt beck is one of
the first people to interact with them
and appears to be familiar with leyla's
past it isn't long before mark gets
caught acting suspiciously and the
fighting begins as moon knight springs
into action layla keeps spec busy beck
uses a knife during his altercation with
layla which makes total sense as his
comic book counterpart utilizes glass
knives filled with acidic fluids it's a
somewhat strange choice of a weapon but
one fitting an assassin who belongs to
an organization called the slayer's
elite in the comics those acid-filled
blades would be the end of beck he fell
on them while trying to murder moon
knight and died as a result
when his contact in cairo is murdered by
men loyal to amit mark spector has no
choice but to beat the information he
needs out of the killers he shows some
hesitation when it comes to hitting the
youngest of these assailants who is
stylishly dressed in a denim jacket the
print on the back of his jacket is
mostly white with a spattering of teal
and purple but the design itself is
what's interesting here only extremely
perceptive viewers and comic book
scholars will recognize this as a
reference to pharaoh ramatutt ramitat is
one of the many incarnations of kang the
conqueror or in mcu terms he who remains
who fans met in the loki series as a
time traveler kang has a long and
complicated history ramitat is one of
the many personas he's adopted during
his infinite quest to control time
throughout the series there are multiple
hints that mark was somehow involved in
the murder of leyla's father layla
naturally presses mark to find out the
truth which is finally revealed when
mark says my partner got greedy in me
[Music]
he executed everyone at dick's site
viewers later learned what comics fans
already knew that mark's partner was a
vicious killer named raul bushman pretty
much everything we see in the show is
right out of the comics when mark tried
to stop bushmen from murdering a group
of archaeologists bushman shot mark and
left him for dead leading to konchu's
intervention and the creation of moon
knight there is one difference though in
the comics mark's lover is called
marlene the show took marlene's
backstory including mark's involvement
in the death of her father and used it
to create the new character of leila
abdallah al fuli given how much his
relationship with mark has been set up
chances seem pretty high that we'll
eventually see bushmen in the tv show
whether or not we'll see the gruesome
end of their rivalry remains to be seen
as in the comics moon knight killed him
by cutting his face off that doesn't
sound very disney
after mark spector is shot by harrow he
falls into a pool of water he wakes up
in what appears to be some sort of
asylum complete with bingo orderlies
what looks like an authentic marvel moon
knight action figure as well as plenty
of familiar faces and a drawing of
konshu there are many things present to
convince steven that everything he
thought had been going on for the last
four episodes didn't happen but the best
may be tombuster this fake vhs tape is a
mixture of indiana jones and tomb raider
a low budget title that our hero could
be pulling his fantasies from with the
appropriate amount of cheesy dialogues
sets and knock-off music at least now we
know what happened to paulman tobin
yes
and to anyone who chooses a path of
greed
it's a clever setup a brilliant change
of pace and allows ethan hawk to channel
carl jung who the actor told
entertainment weekly helped guide his
portrayal of the asylum version of
harrow what viewers may not know though
is that this setting was inspired by the
2016 comic story moon knight lunatic
which put mark in this exact position to
examine his grasp on reality
in the final moments of episode 4 mark
spector and steven grant are surprised
to run into a giant hippopotamus and who
can blame them hi
it may be a giant anthropomorphic
creature dressed in ancient egyptian
garb but considering their current
situation her appearance turns out to be
a blessing this is taweret the egyptian
goddess of childbirth and fertility as
much as her appearance might have been a
surprise to some viewers it was actually
set up in the first episode while
working in the museum gift shop donna
asks grant to grab a box of stuffed
hippos which leads him to offering some
unwanted info on who taweret is it's a
small reference that also helps to show
off more of our hero's vast egyptian
knowledge and this little tidbit makes
for an entertaining note during a
re-watch
part of episode 5 sees taweret the hippo
goddess acting as a sort of post-life
tour guide for mark and steven after
some joint yelling the two begin to
realize that this depiction of putnam
medical facility called putnam
psychiatric hospital in the comics where
mark spector was sent as a kid is
actually a part of their journey through
the afterlife but the hospital itself
isn't the only easter egg during the
conversation taweret mentions that there
are other versions of the afterlife as
well you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist yeah ah like the
ancestral plane oh just gorgeous
this isn't just another part of egyptian
mythology she's praising however but the
ancestral plane from the black panther
film this is a fun line that brings moon
knight a bit closer to the mcu proper it
makes perfect sense that taweret would
mention it as well considering her
connection to bast who in egyptian
mythology was a cat goddess and in the
mcu is the panther goddess of wakanda we
mostly see it as a place where the
various black panthers journey to speak
to the dead and seek wisdom but there is
potentially much more that could be done
with this realm if marvel ever wanted to
do a small crossover into the afterlife
shown at the end of moon night
in episode 5 mark spector and steven
grant attempt to balance their scales
and that means exploring several deep
memories and facing some harsh truths
about their past part of this is
learning about the death of a boy
affectionately called roro who is
actually randall rand spector mark's
younger brother in this mcu version of
moon knight mark is blamed for the
unexpected accident that takes his
brother's life things are somehow even
worse in the comics though in the show
mark's mother accuses him of being
jealous of his younger sibling but it's
the other way around in the source
material rand doesn't die as a child but
instead grows up to be an insane serial
killer supervillain called hatchet man
who is obsessed with destroying his
older brother mark rand eventually
becomes a twisted mirror of moon knight
called shadow knight and the punisher is
forced to kill him to end his reign of
terror does rand's rich comic history
imply that the mcu version may have
somehow survived given that ancient gods
brought mark back from the dead twice
during the course of the show
anything is possible
as mark and stephen journey through
their collective mind we are shown
several interesting things but most of
the heart catch references were in their
childhood room much of the bedroom is
set up purposefully to look as did in
the run of comics by jeff lemire and
greg smallwood this includes the race
car bed and a specific poster on the
wall for star wars episode 4 a new hope
which doubles as a nod to actor oscar
isaac being a part of the franchise in
the newest trilogy there are also toys
lying around pictures on the walls and a
cubs banner to let everyone know we're
in chicago but a couple of things may
have gone unnoticed the item that comes
into focus first is the name bluebird on
the wing of an airplane which some comic
book scholars think may reference an
obscure spider-man character though it's
possibly just a coincidence however in
that same shot we get our first glance
at the many astronaut figures that the
imaginative young hero has this is
likely another comic reference to
another personality of marx who was an
astronaut that fought werewolves
which might sound like an odd
combination but astronaut werewolves are
surprisingly common in the marvel
universe also more simply astronauts go
to the moon and moon knight is well you
get the idea finally just below the
scales in mark's room another recurring
motif throughout the show is a pair of
grey nunchaku in the comics the fist of
konshu originally uses a truncheon to
fight with which he first modifies for
use as nunchaku in the 1980 issue moon
knight number two these are a couple of
nice subtle nods that don't feel out of
place in the childhood memory and may
have helped influence mark's future
adventures
there's so much to see in young mark's
bedroom but one thing in particular
stands out that was made just for the
show the tomb buster poster if you look
closely you can see a couple fun things
on it doug purlin is the name given to
the lead actor for tombuster which is a
clever homage to moon knight's creators
doug mensch and don perlin and the
poster also shows that the film was
presented by timely atlas studios which
is another instance of two names timely
comics and atlas comics shoved together
timely is what marvel comics was known
as in the 1940s while atlas is what they
were called in the 1950s it's an
extremely deep cut for most viewers but
that poster also begs to be stared at so
it works out
before the show's release many viewers
were wondering about whether or not this
iteration of moon knight in the mcu
would remain jewish as he is in the
comics his heritage and religion are a
key part of mark spector especially
since his father was a rabbi it's a deep
part of the character and important for
representation thankfully there was some
hope given to those who wanted to see
this mentioned in the series when
director muhammad diob posted on twitter
that fans who were curious about that
aspect of the character would be pleased
and they were while in the asylum going
through their memories mark and steven
must discuss their mother's death which
brings up the line dad called me after
all these years
about her shiva and i couldn't
i couldn't do it
in judaism shiva is the first seven days
of mourning the observance of which is
sometimes referred to as sitting shiva
in english plus when the two characters
revisit this specific memory we also see
mark dressed in all black wearing a
yamaka these elements give the audience
insights into mark's religious
background and acknowledge his following
of the traditions all while mark and
steven are dealing with the weight of
their own present death
just as mark and steven begin working
together and find their balance one of
them has to go and get thrown overboard
during the fight at the end of episode 5
steven taps into the side of mark that
can wield a bat just before he throws
himself into helping mark a bit too much
and hits the sands at first he tries to
catch up with the boat but steven is
quickly overcome by sans freezing him
there it's a sad scene that comes just
when things are looking up but we all
should have seen it coming because it
was actually teased right at the start
of the series in the first episode when
stephen grant is still blissfully
ignorant of his other life he shows off
his knowledge in the museum where he
works he speaks to a young girl about
pyramids death and being judged only for
her to come back at him with a couple of
confusing questions including and did it
suck for you getting rejected from the
field of reads what if that makes sense
because i'm not dead am i
stephen is understandably confused but
now we know that the child was either
aware of his future or perhaps just a
bit cruel
we all knew layla was destined for great
things but the season one moon knight
finale nearly outdoes itself in that
regard when layla unexpectedly becomes a
superhero herself after rejecting the
offer to become the avatar of konshu she
instead becomes an avatar of taweret
after harrow attempts to bury her inside
the pyramid laila is seen bursting
through the wall in a glorious new
costume she wastes no time with her
newfound powers fighting by her
husband's side and saving lives after
she rescues one group an awestruck girl
asks the new avatar if she's an egyptian
superhero and it's a big moment for a
lot of people
it wasn't really unexpected though as
there were hints throughout including
konchu calling her a quote little bug
that's significant because layla may or
may not be a version of the comic
character scarlet scarab in the comics
the scarlet scarab is an egyptian
superhero identity taken on by a father
and son duo named faul naturally fans
connected the dots between the scarlet
scarab and this new mcu hero embodied by
leila elfuli however there are some
differences as the comics version of
scarlet scarab is not connected to
tawere but rather gets his powers from
an ancient magical artifact moon knight
director mohammed diov has been coy
about whether or not leila is
technically scarlet scarab telling
collider that while unofficially she is
the scarlet scarab they intentionally
left it vague so they could officially
decide later on set we were calling her
scarlet scarab i would love to keep it
open because i don't know how things are
going to go i'd rather keep it open for
her
the post-credits scene in the season
finale of moon knight pleased many fans
with the final reveal of the jake
lockley personality as well as the
comics accurate depictions of the white
limo complete with spectre vanity plates
and conscious crisp suit but there's
another fun easter egg that avid readers
would have spotted the name of the
facility that arthur harrow has been
abducted from is the cenkevich
psychiatric hospital named after
renowned comic book artist bilson kevich
cinkevich is a prolific and
revolutionary artist known for his
uncommon style and methods of blending
in traits from other practitioners of
the craft sim cabbage not only worked on
the first moon night book in 1980 but he
provided many great covers and insides
for the hero for years afterward in fact
many believe that the character of moon
knight owes much of its success to
sankevich it seems fitting that the show
which will hopefully help mark and
company to continue to grow with more
new fans pays tribute to him in a fun
way during the final scene check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]